JAMES MCGILL: Hi, I'm James
McGill, one of the software
engineers on the
Google Maps API,
based out of beautiful
Sydney, Australia.
I'm here in Logan, Utah, at
the headquarters of iFit,
for the world's first
digital 5-kilometer run.
CHASE WATTERSON: Last week, we
took a runner with us to France
to run the beautiful
streets of Paris.
And her iFit watch tracked
all the information on her run
and stored it in the iFit cloud.
So when she landed back
at iFit headquarters,
she was able to share that exact
run she experienced in Paris
with all of the runners here.
On the treadmill
console, they were
able to see the
exact same streets
that she saw and even
feel the same incline
and decline of those streets.
JARED MECHAM: While
we were going uphill,
the treadmill went up.
Going downhill, the
treadmill went down.
It was incredible.
AMY PETERSON: It was
doing it for you,
and you're getting
this amazing workout.
It was so fun.
JAMES MCGILL: You're no
longer just staring at a wall.
You get to visit
everywhere in the world,
and you get to get fit
while you're doing it.
ERIKA PETERSON: It's not
a boring treadmill run.
You can literally run anywhere
in the world any time you want.
SADIE JANE: Phenomenal-- unlike
any other treadmill experience
I've had.
JAMES MCGILL: This Is one
of the most incredible,
out-of-the-box integrations
that I've ever seen.
And the best thing
about it is that it's
making everybody's life better.
CHASE WATTERSON: IFit and Google
have completely changed the way
that you view fitness.